maybe she's done this before she said
she had it right did she tell you she
was a virgin too
so um you guys think about this new unit
that all depends on the sergeant major
if he's easy it's easy then we're [ __ ]
out a lot cuz I know the new sergeant
major names Plumlee Plumlee
sounds like pansy yeah did we tell you
about plum lamb I've been in about six
months when they assigned me this heavy
weapons unit in the platoon sergeant as
the nastiest looking mother I ever saw
all scarred up one bad bastard made this
green lieutenant fresh out of university
ROTC he orders us to go back one day and
pin on our ribbons what every been
awarded so we can see what kind of man
he's got we go back put on her stuff and
reassemble but the sergeant he didn't
put his ribbons on so lieutenant choose
him out in front of the whole universe
me to go back in on his dress you return
to the barracks immediately and pin
every award on your chest do you
understand me sergeant about ten minutes
sorry she comes back
not one Medal of Honor around his neck
but two besides that naked as a jaybird
it was Plumlee not a sergeant with doing
well what the hell that's where I got to
do a plumber because Plumlee is mcdoon
boss mcdoon he was scared shitless of
Plumlee
Lorna's hard to maegyr
adenine what kind of god damn day